e aí
o esporte é minha vida o esporte é minha
grande paixão comecei na infância dos
meus 9 aos 18 anos dançando jazz balé
até que eu entrei para a faculdade e
abandonei as danças
e quando eu conheci meu namorado hoje o
meu marido ele me apresentou a corrida
de rua posso dizer que foi picada pelo
bichinho da corrida em pouco tempo já
estava correndo provinha de 5 e 10km
quando eu vi já tinha me inscrito em
meia-maratona e até mesmo numa maratona
foi então que eu resolvi comprar uma
bicicleta para represar os treinos
corrida que acabou lesionando muito
devido o impacto ao solo quando eu vi já
estava nadando também foi aí que eu
conheci alguns amigos na academia que me
apresentaram o triathlon é um esporte
tão envolvente e ao mesmo tempo tão
desafiador e eu decidi treinar criação
também comecei em 2011 com provinhas
curtas de short triathlon triathlon
olímpico até me inscrever em distâncias
maiores que seria um meio ironman era
fevereiro de 2018 rio mãe de dois
meninos de 1 e 4 anos vive um mês
especialmente agitado de trem
bom senso pois estava na preparação para
o meio ironman florianópolis no qual é o
largaria para completar uma prova muito
desafiadora essa prova consiste em nada
1.900 metros pedalar 90 km e por fim
ainda correr uma meia maratona 21km não
era fácil conciliar treinos cuidado com
os pequenos ea vida familiar foi então
que meu treinador me ligou bruna se
inscrever para uma outra prova esta
prova sim seria a mais dura de todas a
mais pesada só que eu decidi eu vou
encarar essa corrida eu vou até o final
eu não vou baixar a cabeça para essa
prova eu decidi enfrentar aquela corrida
como se fosse para minha própria
sobrevivência
e essa corrida era extremamente
desafiadora imagine uma ultramaratona ou
uma ironman que exige um esforço
gigantesco do seu organismo com horas de
treinos tendo que abrir mão várias vezes
o prazer imediato do conforto do
cantinho ali com a família e tudo para
colher lá na frente a vitória na linha
de chegada essa prova teria vários
obstáculos que eu nem os conhecia sequer
imaginava era tudo muito novo e intensa
para mim o primeiro motivo era a notícia
da grave lesão passado o choque inicial
eu teria que enfrentar um primeiro
grande obstáculo
e essa era a distância que eu precisaria
de tomar em relação ao meus filhos pois
aquele momento eu não poderia tê-los em
minha companhia e aquilo era pior das
sensações pois sabemos que não existe
nada maior do que o amor de uma mãe para
com seus filhos especialmente eu que
sempre fui presente desde o dia do
nascimento até aquela inesperada
surpresa os iscos de insucesso no início
da corrida eram muito grande que geraram
uma negação total que me afastou dos
pequenos nessa corrida eu olhava pela
janela e eu me sentia numa prisão esta
era a segunda barreira principalmente eu
que acordo cedinho todas as manhãs para
prova praticamente atividades físicas ao
ar livre pela linda ufv pois hoje hoje
eu moro em viçosa e eu considero aquela
universidade meu parque de diversões de
treinos de pedal de corrida então não
poder sentir os
o meu corpo senti meu rosto era uma
sensação muito estranha
é algo que me trazia apreensão
diariamente era receber inúmeras
intervenções sem saber o horário ou a
extensão da dor a fim de que os
resultados preliminares do meu
desempenho me permitissem dar a largada
meus braços e minhas veias já que
pareciam ressecados todo aquele
sacrifício para me manter em condições
mínimas para corrida tirou a força de
meus braços que muitas vezes não me
permite não pegar no celular para
conversar com meus filhos vocês time eu
sentia que aquele corpo já não era mais
meu estava à disposição deles para todos
os tipos de procedimento todos aqueles
dias eu precisava enfrentar o risco da
eliminação e entretanto eu era
surpreendida com os resultados no início
de enfrentamento para para a lesão dessa
grande corrida os resultados eram muito
internos pouco consistência outra
objeção era uma prova muito dolorida
realizadas regularmente para avaliar ohm
o caso e se não fosse factorio seria
necessário usar outros tipos de recursos
e houve um dia né tão longa corrida que
eu não estava me sentindo muito bem sabe
aqueles dias que você acorda cansada tem
vontade nenhuma de treinar já de saco
cheio e mesmo assim você sabe que
precisa ir e vai e apesar de não ser o
melhor treino de não ser o melhor
pescoço você encara o desafio pois sabe
que lá na frente lá na linha de chegada
será recompensador sabia que passou por
tudo aquilo mas buscou a sua medalha é
um sentimento maior é o dever cumprido
do atleta
em determinado momento da corrida eu me
encontrava com temperaturas altíssimas
já vi usado todos os tipos de
intervenções possíveis e nada sentir o
risco do fracasso iminente apesar de
toda a prostração no percurso eu
precisava me submeter a uma avaliação
final de desempenho teria eu a chance da
vitória em caso negativo toda minha
trajetória teria sido em vão e eu teria
que começar uma outra corrida de nova
linha de largada
já sabe quando vem aquela dorzinha no
canto da barriga quando você está
correndo muito forte e não consegue
respirar direito tamanho desgaste a
tendência é que toda atleta diminui o
ritmo ou até mesmo desista aquela era a
minha sensação apesar de toda a carga
emocional negativa eu precisava de
correr com a cabeça erguida eu tinha
consciência que em breve aqueles
resultados serão positivos e que logo eu
estaria entre as primeiras colocadas de
minha categoria
e eu passei naquele naquele desafio eu
superei com isso poderia continuar e
devia naquele momento eu confiei mais e
mais que deus lhe carregaria no colo
durante toda aquela prova até a tão
sonhada a linha de chegada eu tinha fé
que ele queria para mim vitória vitória
para voltar a cuidar dos meus filhos tão
pequeninos e que ainda tanto precisavam
de mim passados alguns dias eu recebi a
notícia da conclusão da primeira etapa
da corrida finalmente uma boa nova tudo
que foi proposto até ali eu havia
superado com sucesso isso encheu meu
coração de alegria sabendo que a
dinheiro chegava se aproximava
e nenhum esporte nem aqueles individuais
são concluídos por apenas uma pessoa
atrás de toda atleta campeão existe uma
equipe super bem preparada e acima de
tudo comprometida com o resultado
almejado na minha opinião a minha equipe
foi a maior ea melhor de todas por isso
naquele momento eu só queria agradecer
pela esse time não foi recrutado por mim
mas certamente foi deus que escolheu
cada um dos 512 voluntários era uma
legião de anjos que tiraram um tempinho
do seu dia para um gesto lindo no gesto
nobre uma atitude que salva vidas os
organizadores da grande corrida vieram
até o meu encontro me agradecer dizendo
que em cinco anos de trabalho naquele
local nunca tinha visto uma campanha tão
grande e tão linda como a minha foram
bênçãos enviados do céu toda aquela
campanha me fez sentir mais forte mais
veloz para
a dourada naquele momento eu tive a
certeza que minha lesão estava sendo
curada e eu a sentia cada vez mais
próxima
e eu tinha até essa grande corridas
surpresa o sonho de largada nesta prova
mas eu sei que a corrida a mais
importante a essa que eu tive que
participar foi de todas a mais
importante a partir dessa vitória o novo
propósito foi definido para minha vida
e então eu pude concluir e confirmar que
toda minha força toda minha dedicação ou
triathlon me deram uma mente positiva
tolerância e paciência igual abre para
superar todos os obstáculos que eu
enfrentei nesta grande corrida
e durante a competição eu tive 5 dias em
casa com meus filhos com a minha família
para buscar aquele fôlego extra para os
quilômetros finais da segunda parte da
prova
e foram cinco semanas consecutivas e
derradeiras de treino duro percurso
intenso sabendo que ainda era possível
isso todas aquela de intercorrências da
fase anterior porém a minha força a
minha fé foram tão fortes que nada
aconteceu passei o período daquela prova
o maior desafio de minha vida o
propósito de buscar a medalha de ouro me
encheu de coragem e serviu de fio
condutor para superar todos aqueles
obstáculos eu prometi para mim mesma que
eu tento finalizada aquela grande prova
surpresa no ano seguinte eu iria em
florianópolis buscar a minha medalha só
que agora como a saúde plena e abundante
e sabem qual corrida tão importante
inesperada foi esta vejam família a
nesse querido portanto não a doutora
ilda acabou de sair daqui e deu o
diagnóstico de uma leucemia aguda me
falou que eu tenho chá de cura que eu
vou fazer o tratamento a princípio vou
ficar três semanas aqui no hospital
fazendo a quimioterapia venosa com
recebendo a as plaquetas então vou fazer
todo esse tratamento aqui e eu tenho
certeza que eu vou vencer entender o
chance de cura eu tenho certeza que eu
sou uma pessoa forte sempre fui sempre
lutei pela minha vida pela vida dos meus
filhos e conto com vocês com as orações
com carinho com amor de toda minha
família e todos meus amigos amo vocês
vou precisar da força de vocês mas vou
vencer essa em nome de jesus nossa
senhora minha mãezinha tá lá em cima
olho olhando por mim como sempre olhou
sem
oi gil e vai continuar vai dar certo
amém foram dois meses 7 dias internada
no hospital tomando quimioterapia
transfusões sanguíneas diárias infecções
febres creme diz que era inflamações das
veias não foi fácil período longe dos
meus filhos mas tem plena certeza da
vitória quando eles iam me visitar eu
colocar uma peruca para eles não se
assustarem tanto então brincar vamos
como podia
a minha médica meu anjo protetor as
orações no hospital os pedidos de doação
tang e a prova que eu prometi no leito
do hospital que eu iria voltar no ano
seguinte e buscar a minha verdade só que
agora com a saúde plena e abundante
[Música]
é um sofia então você pode passar para
todo mundo essa hora não tá bom começa
hora eu falo eu vim aqui eu só vou
escrever nessa prova e eu prometi para
mim ver lá no leito do hospital que eu
iria vir aqui buscar minha medalha do
meio ironman então eu tô aqui com saúde
plena feito obrigada senhor por essa
chance de vida nova e eu peguei a minha
medalha é
o que eu aprendi com essa grande corrida
a valorizar os pequenos e grandes
momentos todos extremamente valiosos de
respirar um beijinho carinhoso de bom
dia aos filhos o de ser grata a deus
pelo simples fato de acordar saudável o
de ter tempo de qualidade com a família
e especialmente nunca desistir dos
sonhos os mais puros desejos do coração
finalmente sorrir sorrir sempre pois
essa é minha marca a menina energia
mesmo em dias difíceis naquele hospital
eu sempre colocava um sorriso no rosto
pois eu sabia que aquilo amenizaria as
minhas dores e no dia vinte de maio de
2018 eu recebi a ligação de minha médica
dizendo que eu estava curada remissão
completa da doença aquilo veio como um
bálsamo para o meu coração que estava
tão inquieto ea felipe comemora o meu no
renascimento naquela data
a gratidão eterna a deus por essa chance
de vida nova gratidão a toda equipe
médica e aos 512 doadores de sangue que
aqui eu chamo de voluntários por isso eu
deixo aqui o meu apelo a vocês que estão
aí com a saúde plena tira um tempinho do
seu dia para esse gesto tão lindo tão
nobre que realmente salva vidas eles
ajudaram a salvar a minha vida e você
pode salvar a vida de alguém valoriza a
sua vida a sua saúde pois sem ela nada
somos eu descobri que até para dois ter
é preciso ter saúde se não fosse pela
minha qualidade de vida minha dedicação
ao esporte talvez várias e percorrencia
iriam surgir no meio do caminho então xô
preguiça bora cuidar da saúde esporte é
vida obrigado a vocês que tiver aqui
hoje você tá minha história de superação
e vitória gratidão
e aí